trente cinq ans après la sortie du
célèbre dessin animé les 101 dalmatiens
sont de retour mercredi sur nos écrans
mais cette fois en chair et en os en
hausse si je puis dire pour ses aimables
toutou avec une cruella d'enfer
interprété par glenn close aux états
unis ce film a déjà engrangé plus de 700
millions de francs de recettes
les dessins animés c'est sympa mais
finalement rien ne vous les personnages
en poils en chair et en os c'est le
petit clin d'oeil de studios disney qui
s'est lancé dans l'adaptation d'un de
ses classiques
c'est ainsi que vous retrouverez sans un
petit dalmatiens leur maître ranger et
anita leurs parents père ly et pongo et
l'heure et demie une cruella d'enfer
comme vous n'osiez l'imaginer dans vos
pires cauchemars
tout ce petit monde prêt à vous rejouer
l'histoire terrible de cette vilaine
dame qui ne portait que de la fourrure
et qui rêvait d'un manteau en peau de
dalmatien dans la version filmée cruella
et même la redoute est propriétaire
d'une maison de couture spécialisée dans
la peau de bête
une ravissante petite bête oui c'est une
dalmatienne âge vous inspirer oui poids
lourds au cours du rouble citoyens
un peu dur c'est à dire mais il était
froid aux yeux quand elle était bébé
nous sauver alors quel effet ça fait
d'être devenu le cauchemar numéro 1 2
million d'enfants dans l'inde est vieux
je pense que finalement ce n'est pas une
mauvaise chose
les un dalmatien c'est un conte
classique dans lequel s'affrontent le
bien et le mal
alors c'est très important de donner
aussi un visage au mal
fiable j'entendais matin ils sont forts
ces gens n'ont pas ménagé non plus tard
ils n'en ont pas mais la naissance vous
en êtes sûre et certaine
mais télé - dans 20 sacs
je prends tout cas partie il ya cette
scène où je viens réclamer les chiots la
chine qui jouait la mère était
terrorisée par mon personnage quand je
me suis penché au dessus du beignet elle
a pris la fuite il a fini 4e prier pour
quelques mois car la présence de
centaines de chiens sur le plateau il
fallait les remplacer dès qu'il
grandissait n'a bien sûr pas été une
mince affaire
il paraît que les chiens ont adoré
l'expérience et qu'ils espèrent bien
tourné le retour des 101 dalmatiens
en attendant cette version filmée ravira
les possibles et par an
ceux là même qui découvrait le dessin
animé il y à 35 ans
logique